the theorem implies that there will be
an infinite number of undecidable
sentences sentences which are true which
cannot be proved so because then you
might hope well we could just add those
finite number as axioms and then we will
have a complete this is the
incompleteness is referring to the fact
that there's this kind of gap between
truth and proof we'd love a complete
system where we've got a set of axioms
and all truths can be proved so
incompleteness refers to the fact that
you can never kind of complete it
how will a mathematician ever know if
what they're working on is truly
undecidable or falls into the girdle but
it seems like you could have things in
your too hard back and you just say oh
this must be a girdle problem I think
that's one of the real challenges for
mathematicians and I think most of us
actually kind of slightly stick our head
in the sand and go well lol oh no I
don't really don't want to know about
that because and I think it's important
when you're going into trying to prove a
theorem that you believe you can prove
it
I mean there are other issues actually
about prove ability which are complexity
issues we know that there are some
proofs that will be of a complexity that
our human mind will never be able to
navigate we sort of feel like number
theory throws up statements which are
easy to to write down but the complexity
look at fermat's last theorem that the
complexity of that is immense compared
to these statements of there being no
solutions to these equations and we know
just for mathematical reasons there will
be statements which whose proofs are of
a length that even the universe as a
consider the universe as a computer it
will not be able to to crunch out before
time ends i think thats girdle's
revelation did change people's a kind of
conception about mathematics because i
think their walls are feeling like we
should be able to prove anything that's
that's true so i think there was a kind
of shift but you know that's just
something we have to have
to deal with it gives mathematics and
interesting sort of complexity to it
that wasn't there before so and there's
something intriguing about the way that
we as humans can pull ourselves outside
a system and this actually has been used
by some to suggest that this is why
human consciousness is actually much
more than just an analog computer
because how can an analog computer pull
itself out of a system that is stuck
within yet we seem to be able to shift
from outside the system to see meaning
of that sentence go inside the system
prove that it can't be proved but you
know for someone like Roger Penrose has
used girdle as a kind of challenge to
whether human consciousness can ever be
captured by something like like a
conventional computer there is a
challenge to to that kind of idea of
saying you were humans are better than
the machines and because the challenge
is that even when we're working outside
the system we are ourselves still
working within another system which
we're assuming is consistent doesn't
have contradictions but we're having to
make that assumption so so I think that
is this feeling like well we're better
than the machine well we have to
remember that we're also limiting
ourselves within our own system of
logical thought there's a lovely
sentence because we can't prove that one
of girdle's conclusions is that we
cannot prove that mathematics does not
have contradictions in it and that's
also very unsettling I mean it's amazing
we've been doing mathematics for several
thousand years and nobody's come up with
any contradiction so that's the good
evidence that it does work but that's
not to say that there might not be some
really subtle thing which will crash it
and I think that we really had to think
about this very carefully when Russell
was coming up with paradoxes about set
theory we had to have a new conception
about set because of his challenge of
paradoxes which seem to be things which
were quite mathematical in nature but
there's a lovely quote by one of my
heroes Andre Vey
French mathematician number theorist who
says you know God exists because
mathematics is consistent the devil
exists because we cannot prove that it
is consistent when you look at what
girdle did what was it about his theorem
that was brilliant or a leap or clever
like what what what was the new thing he
came up with and all the old people
before hand thought of what was the
brilliance of it at girdle's brilliance
was this idea of allowing mathematics to
talk about itself and at its heart is
this idea of being able to code every
statement in mathematics with its own
unique code number and I mean I like it
because you know one of my obsessions as
people might know is prime numbers and
girdle uses the primes very cleverly to
produce this coding so essentially every
logical symbol get it gets its own sort
of prime number and the number of times
it's used where it's used it's kind of
coded in the power of that time and I
think this was really the extraordinary
revelation that mathematics could be
self referential how could you talk
about proving things in mathematics
mathematically but using this coding
there was a way to do it so for me that
was the brilliance of girdle all
statements all symbols everything can be
coded using these numbers can you give
me some idea how big these numbers are
it's not like a plus size of 7 and a
divide sign is a 13 a weekly like mega
numbers they start really small you
don't need to
so the first logical symbol will have
the prime to the second 1 3 5 7 and so
but the point is that when you're
actually taking a statement or of
mathematics and looking at its code
number that will be a product of all of
these Prime's the the pair of the prime
will be also indicating something about
the structure of that sentence so once
you start multiplying all of these
Prime's together you get incredibly huge
numbers um but you're right the
ingredients are are really the first few
prime numbers so yeah
I thought I was to go and get Andrew
while the famous proof and strip it back
to its barest of bare bones which is
still pretty massive it was I could spit
out a number at the end that could be
printed out on a piece of paper yes it
means that the statement of Fermat's
Last Theorem itself will have a code
number but every single logical step in
that proof will have its own code number
and so you can write down the proof of
Fermat's Last Theorem as one whacking
great number has it change the subject
that changed mathematics or is it just
this landmines out there that you all
hope you're not stepping on I think that
we kind of have to have this arrogant
belief that the thing we're working on
we can prove it's almost part of the
makeup of being a mathematician is that
I mean you know it's not just good or
it's about saying well maybe this is so
complex my brain isn't going to manage
to prove it I think it's amazing how
much mathematics we are able to capture
with our the finite equipment in our
head so I don't think it really has
changed to fundamentally the mindset of
the mathematician but we all have to be
wary of that
there's a lovely novel by Apostolos
doxiadis called uncle Petros and the
Goldbach conjecture and this is about a
Greek mathematician he's been working on
the Goldbach conjecture and he then
firmly discovers it's set in the 1930s
he suddenly comes across this work of
girdle and it completely undermines his
his work that what if what if this is a
statement which is true which doesn't
have a proof and I tell you Goldbach has
a kind of feel of that because it's sort
of combining two things that probably
shouldn't have anything to do with each
other addition and the atoms of
multiplication the primes so it might
just be something which happens to be
true
but doesn't really have a good proof
from the axioms
girdle's incompleteness theorem really
captured the public imagination because
it sort of seemed to show a limitations
of knowledge and people kind of like
that idea
and it seems to show that mathematics
wasn't as powerful as people thought but
I think you have to be cautious here
because the weird thing is that we can
prove that that statement is true it's
just working outside the system it's a
so you know we're still pretty powerful
mathematicians but but I think it does
show that with any within any system
there will be limitations so I think you
know I spent the last three years on
this kind of journey inspired by girdle
to look at the other Sciences to see
whether they have their own statements
which by their very nature may be
unknowable I think there's this kind of
thing that maybe science can know it all
but Sam you know so are there any kind
of other Sciences which have similar
sort of limitations on what they could
possibly know lots of things we don't
know now but maybe there are questions
that by their nature we can never know
there's a lovely story that Hilbert goes
to become an honorary citizen of his
hometown of coningsburgh
he's given this great honor and he makes
his declaration the other Muslims out of
India a dozen Bowden Illinois German
isn't good enough we must know we shall
know this belief that there is no what
he called ignoramus
no ignorant what he didn't realize is a
girdle in the same town of knigsberg a
few days earlier had given his talk
about this great new theorem the
incompleteness theorem showing that
ignore Bemis is actually part of
mathematics and also it seems like I
should be number one it seems so
fundamental it should have intuitively
well it's interesting because Hilbert's
first problem does relate to something
that girdle was also interested in which
is the nature of infinity so it's
something called the continuum
hypothesis which asks if there an
infinite set between the countable
numbers and the continuum the set the
size of the continuum the size of all
the real numbers maybe there's an
infinite set between those now here's an
interesting example of a challenge
mathematically surely we should be able
to work that out
it turns out thanks to girdle and a
Cohen as well that you can choose your
answer so you can't prove within
mathematics that either this is true or
is negation is true so much so that you
can actually put either in as an axiom
and if mathematics was consistent before
it's still consistent goodwill
did have make some other interesting
contributions not just a mathematics to
physics he took he was a great friend of
Einstein in Princeton they used to walk
to the Institute for Advanced Study
together in the morning and he looked at
the science equations for general
relativity and he showed that there's a
solution of those equations where time
is circular so you get these loops
happening now we presume that can't
physically happen because that would
imply certain paradoxes like the
grandfather paradox you'd be able to go
back and kill your grandfather but it's
fascinating that girdle again was able
to prove these slightly paradoxical
solutions to the theory of general
relativity the other intriguing thing he
did was he took the American
Constitution and he discovered a logical
inconsistency in that which completely
invalidated any statement he would make
and so when he became an American
citizen I think he was going to raise
this and say well actually you realize
that that there's a logical
inconsistency which completely
invalidates any statement that some here
and I think he was encouraged not to
bring that out puts his some kind of
ceremony to become a citizen don't--all
had a really tragic ends because he
became very paranoid when he was in
America that people were trying to
poison him and he he says she starved
himself to death because he was so
terrified that any food was was was
actually going to kill him so it's a
kind of sad ending to an extraordinary
life truth value to it but then when I
went up to university I realized that
mathematics you can't have those yet
when I took this course on mathematical
logic and we learned about girdle's
incompleteness theorem